-Yeah!
Performing "Rich Man" from their upcoming album, "Mr. Sun,"
give it up for Little Big Town!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah, I'm a rich man ♪
♪ Without a lick of money ♪
♪ A better than blessed man ♪
♪ Had all I ever wanted ♪
♪ 'Cause I got everything I need ♪
♪ Got love and a family ♪
♪ I'm a hardworkin' man ♪
♪ You plant a seed and sow it ♪
♪ A Sunday go-to-church man ♪
♪ 'Cause I need help and know it ♪
♪ But God's been good to me ♪
♪ Better than He had to be ♪
-♪ Yeah, in my soul, one thing I know ♪
♪ I ain't lookin' for a pot of gold ♪
♪ That ain't what this life means to me ♪
♪ I keep my head up high, feet on the ground ♪
♪ Love the ones I'm living 'round ♪
♪ Life is just that simple to me ♪
-♪ Yeah, I'm a rich man ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Gonna tell the truth, man ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ Just like my mama preached it ♪
♪ I'm a red-white-and-blue man ♪
♪ My daddy fought to free it ♪
♪ Man, I still believe ♪
-♪ I still believe ♪
-♪ In the land of the free ♪
♪ Yeah, in my soul, one thing I know ♪
♪ I ain't lookin' for a pot of gold ♪
♪ That ain't what this life means to me ♪
♪ I keep my head up high, feet on the ground ♪
♪ And love the ones I'm livin' 'round ♪
♪ Life is just that simple to me ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm a rich man ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah, I'm a rich man ♪
-♪ Without a lick of money ♪
-♪ A better than blessed man ♪
♪ Had all I ever wanted ♪
♪ 'Cause I got everything I need ♪
-♪ I got everything I need ♪
-♪ Got love and a family ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Ohh!